[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I just wish her all the love and
happiness in the world
[Music]
from the Cinderella Carriage to the
hundreds of roses Britney's 10-minute
ceremony with Sam felt like a fairy tale
she walked in by herself and uh it was
Can't Help Falling in Love
foreign
[Music]
the pop stars off the shoulder Donatella
Versace designed wedding dress had a
portrait neckline a nearly 15 foot long
white tool veil with hand sewn satin
edging and a stream of pearl buttons it
took 700 hours to make as for the bling
the newlyweds went all in wearing more
than half a million dollars in diamonds
overall she was wearing I believe it was
62 carats of diamonds for the day we did
make Britney a heart-shaped necklace and
engraved her wedding date on the back
E.T spoke exclusively with Reverend
Clint huffed he officiated the wedding
and says Brit and Sam kept the vows
traditional it was repeat after me and
they were just completely locked in on
each other it was it was amazing it was
a beautiful moment Brittany got a little
teary-eyed and Sam just reached up and
took care of her with a tissue so who
made the guest list and why Donatella
created the dress Paris Hilton was
Britt's party girl pal back in the early
2000s and she shared more detail on her
this is Paris podcast I was actually
asked to DJ for the president but this
was more important to me it made me so
happy to see that she found her fairy
tale of course Britt's family didn't
make the cut also missing Britney's two
sons with Kevin Federline the boys have
decided that you
they they're they're not seen her
or it's been a few months since they've
actually even seen her they've made the
decision not to go to her wedding Sam
and Brittany held hands almost during
the entire ceremony and it seemed as
though that that kind of grounded them
into the moment that they had each other
at 10 15 PM the newlyweds left in a
white Rolls-Royce the bride hiding in
the back as the party continued without
them for another 45 minutes
just two months later Jennifer Lopez and
Ben Affleck tied the knot at Ben's
Georgia estate fireworks an all-white
dress code and a veil that stretched 20
feet the three-day wedding event did not
disappoint and a source tells E.T Ben
and Jen remain cool calm and collected
through it all
JLo was stunning in a white Ralph Lauren
dress topping off the gorgeous look with
that dramatic sheer cathedral-length
Veil Ben matched his bride wearing a
white tuxedo jacket black trousers and a
black bow tie maybe I'm a shelter
shelter from a broken Paradise I
couldn't dream it any better if I try
ET was outside Ben's very private estate
as the excitement started to unfold
here's the timeline of the wedding
events Matt Damon and his family were
spotted arriving by private plane on
Friday afternoon on Saturday we spotted
Luxury Auto Company on drain Motorsports
getting here around 2 45 with a car
under wraps 3 15 two catering trucks
entered the property and at four o'clock
old Savannah tours entered with some
trolley buses 20 minutes later officiant
Jay Shetty left the Perry Lane Hotel in
Savannah and of course security has been
working around the clock
guests at the Perry Lane Hotel were
greeted with this goodie bag with a JB
inscription on it
in her newsletter Jayla released these
stunning behind the scenes images and
revealed how she pulled off the ultimate
wedding aisle surprise for her True
Companion
Jennifer secretly invited Grammy winner
Mark Cohn to perform his wedding anthem
for her procession down the aisle
because quote Ben and I talked about
True Companion as the perfect wedding
Love Song more than 20 years ago that
was around the time Jennifer told ET
this is there a song you think would be
perfect you can't do that you have to
pick like one together yeah like you
know when you first meet the song that
was playing or when he asked you to
marry him something was in the
background you know what I mean Ben told
JLo seeing Mark Cohn both shocked him
and allowed him to feel the way both
roads we had walked found their way
perfectly together leading up to that
moment Jennifer revealed our five
children preceded me on the walk and
some Old Wounds were healed that day as
the weight of the pass finally lifted
off our shoulders
[Music]
somebody's getting married but before
benefit's glamorous Georgia Eye dues
they exchanged vowels in a little chapel
in Las Vegas with a 180 dollar Tunnel of
Love extravaganza
[Music]
gonna be how you feeling
I'm so excited each he obtained this
exclusive photo inside moments after
they eloped Jennifer wore a white lace
off the shoulder gown from zuher murad's
2023 Bridal collection earlier in the
evening she wore one of her own dresses
from quote an old movie
[Music]
Kourtney Kardashian and Travis Barker
may have given the Affleck some ideas
they got married in Sin City too just
hours after the Grammys in April what
were they wearing the same outfits they
had on after award show One Love Wedding
Chapel owner Marty Frierson took E.T
inside they said vows
um Elvis officiated them and they kissed
and loved and danced they probably
kissed all the way out the door we knew
that Elvis had to marry us but I blacked
out I didn't even remember Elvis like
saying to me walking down the aisle I
didn't remember I had a bouquet I'm like
slurring if you can't hear when Elvis
was marrying us he's like I Chloe take
the Travis and I just like lost my mind
fell straight on the floor but tequila
tequila Courtney is a good person I did
throw up after though and took my top
off and unbuttoned my pants Court
hangover wore off eventually and she
said I do to Travis again in Italy a few
weeks later
foreign
that's Mrs Travis Barker with Mom Chris
negotiating Stone steps an incredibly
long Veil and her custom Dolce Gabbana
white mini dress at the seaside
Portofino estate of the famous designers
as you'd expect her groom also in dng
just couldn't wait for PDA he lifted
Courtney's Veil to give her a kiss
before the ceremony
Court honored her man with her tool
headpiece it's a depiction of the Virgin
Mary matching Travis's head tattoo and
embroidered with the words family
loyalty respect oh we all love it this
is her time to shine baby yeah family
was everywhere from Courtney's ring
bearer son rain to their bridesmaids
daughters Atiana Penelope and Alabama
rounding out the wedding party Kendall
Jenner with her man Devin Booker and
Court's other sisters all going solo
Kylie and floral and blonde Kim she had
her now ex-boyfriend Pete Davidson's
initial embellished on her nail
foreign
the reception at a nearby 16th century
Castle was Peak Kardashian sparklers
multiple outfit changes yes the bride
wore black and a famous Wedding Singer
Andrea Bocelli saying Elvis for the
couple's first dance Kim shimmied in
silver sequins and Chris without Corey
Gamble was pointing up a storm
[Music]
more guests on hand for Courtney's big
day which was fittingly World goth day
who is making it down the aisle first
you two are court and Travis oh cool I'm
not my business
yep kravis's besties Megan Fox in a
black corseted gown posed with her
pink-haired fiance Machine Gun Kelly and
metallic blue leopard MGK Instagram this
cute kravis dance in their matching
white Mr and Mrs Barker leather jackets
[Music]
foreign